trois civils ont été blessés
oui alors ce matin à 6h à cave nous
avons été réveillés par le son des
sirènes et vers 8h30 les premières
explosions ont pu être entendues alors
maintenant l'alerte vient de prendre fin
il y a quelques instants selon le maire
de la ville 16 roquettes russes ont été
arrêtés par la défense aérienne
ukrainienne rien que sur la capitale et
ce sont plus de 120 missiles russes qui
ont visé toute l'Ukraine il y a donc
trois blessés dont une adolescente de 14
ans ici dans la capitale tous les
blessés sont actuellement hospitalisés
et c'est frappes ont aussi un impact sur
le réseau électrique
absolument alors du côté de le vivre une
ville à l'ouest du pays 90% de la ville
est complètement privé d'électricité et
ici à Kiev on s'attend aussi à des
coupures d'électricité et
potentiellement d'eau aussi c'est
souvent le cas après ces frappes
massives russes sur les villes
ukrainiennes et puis le ministre de
l'Énergie il avait déjà dit il y a
quelques jours il faut s'attendre à ce
que ce week-end lors du Nouvel An la
Russie tente à nouveau de détruire les
infrastructures énergétiques du pays
merci beaucoup pour ce point Astrid
Agopian depuis Kiev forces 24